-So we mentioned,
obviously, already in the show
this sort of historic act
about marijuana,
and certainly at
the federal level.
The question I guess is,
you know, it's actually not
that many people
who are affected by it,
but it's such a big step
in the right direction.
What happens next, other than
just pressuring governors
to do the same
on the state level?
Is there -- Do you see
legislation in the future?
-Well, you know,
we've tried over the years,
but let me just start
with saying this.
I strongly believe -- and the
majority of Americans agree --
nobody should have to go to jail
for smoking weed, right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Right? And so we start with
that, and then we are,
to your point, urging --
and the president has been
very clear.
We're urging governors
and states to take our lead
and pardon people
who've been criminalized
for possession of marijuana.
And ultimately, though,
as with so many issues,
if Congress acts,
then there is a uniform approach
to this
and so many other issues.
But Congress needs to act.
We're 29 days away
from the midterms.
Ask who you're voting for
where they stand on this,
and I encourage you to vote
accordingly.